growing concerns over kovid's delta
variant have caused many cities to
reimpose some lockdown error
restrictions like mask mandates many
local businesses are wondering what all
this means for them so here to talk
about how kovitz affected their
businesses our dc and florida restaurant
owners dan simons and giorgio's
voguiatzis welcome to both of you thank
you so much for being with us uh dan i
want to start with you you're in d.c
where unlike in florida there is no
legislation banning vaccine passports
new york city they are as you know
requiring them to enter restaurants are
you nervous that any change could
potentially impact your business what
are you feeling as you're seeing all
this differing guidance come in
it would certainly help us if there was
clear guidance you know my preference
obviously for the economy for safety and
for the sake of our business and our
employees would be that everybody gets
vaccinated you know other than that it's
very difficult as a small business owner
to try to enforce a variety of different
regulations as we try to serve the
public
georgios you've indicated that you're
supportive of the florida governor's
decision to ban vaccine passports
correct me if i'm wrong there he also
suspended fines and penalties for people
who fail to comply with local level mass
mandates but there is considerable
spread of the virus in florida as we're
seeing in other parts of the country
how have you been dealing with that
so we here in miami beach we really
depend on tourism and
i think
is everybody's choice
who is coming down to miami and
everybody's responsibilities
who is concerned and not concerned and
we see here different cases that
we can really
cannot say vaccination not vaccination
but really
it's helping to be protected from covet
i think everybody needs to be in his own
responsibility
to take care of his own health
and
and stay safe
the way that
he thinks it's corrected
dan what do you want to see in order to
avoid another shutdown that could
jeopardize your business because you've
got sort of a different set of
conditions than georgios has in florida
where there's been a pledge from the
governor that there's not going to be
another lockdown
you know i want to keep my employees
safe and i want to keep my business
going and i want to be able to serve as
many diners as possible and buy as much
family farm product as i can so for me
what i want to see is get vaccinated
it's this incredibly easy safe science
based solution that protects the economy
and protects our people our people it's
not complicated are you asking your
employees to get vaccinated or asking
them to volunteer whether they have or
have not been what are you doing with
your business to try to get to that
place
we are both asking our employees and
encouraging them and providing the
vaccination clinics right at the
restaurants to help them we're also
providing education getting folks from
their different communities that might
be able to answer their questions or
help them get over any hesitation so you
know we're encouraging it we're
encouraging it because it keeps them
safe and it helps to helps keep the
business going georgia what are you
doing on your end and could you also
speak to how florida businesses are
feeling are they happy with the
governor's stance or do they feel at all
at risk because of some of this
transmission that we're seeing because
of delta
we don't force our employees to get
vaccinations but we are doing frequently
checks
covet checks because it proved even if
you are vaccinated you can get covered
or you're getting covered after you get
vaccinated
so
we need to be very careful with
everybody's privacy and
and to force people to do something we
don't even know what's the correct thing
i don't think the medicine
has enough research
to
give us a correct information what's the
right thing to do what we do here is
okay we are doing frequently covered
tests and
i'm sorry i have to cut you off we've
really run out of time we're coming up
against a break if you need more
information on vaccines and covet and
delta you can head to foxnews.com we've
got plenty on our page thank you both
for being with us hope to have you back
back again soon